that's the only reason why at the end I
decided that he wasn't touching these
kids and in a sexual way was because of
One Clip Michael Jackson was it a limo
and the girl came up with the titties
yeah he goes goddamn look at them things
he like moved over to the side
was weird he's weird so that's what I
saw that he didn't did all those kids
okay yeah ain't a no way a kid did was
gonna look at two leche duffels yeah
admit interview with Oprah chilling
camera crew in there and he's like
couldn't even be bothered yeah exactly
and he goes look at them exactly look at
the Pelosi's he was calling them
probably because he was seven at the
time
foreign